bonjour je vous parlais de motion design
aujourd'hui quand j'ai commencé à
travailler je faisais ça et des fois ça
et en 2011
j'ai découvert que je pouvais faire ça
je pouvais mettre en mouvement mais
création on appelle ça le motion design
le motion design et l'art de donner vie
à des éléments graphiques des photos des
illustrations des textes des vidéos des
formes des points tout ce que l'on veut
et j'ai fait ce parallèle ce point six
mois ce sont les gens qui nous entourent
c'est vous nous sommes tous des poids
nous sommes tous à un instant t
un point statique et le temps nous
permet de nous mettre en mouvement
imaginé quelques instants la version la
plus âgée de vous même celle que vous
pourriez être au dernier jour de votre
vie ce qui nous lie aujourd'hui à cette
version là et le mouvement que nous
allons donner à ce point avancé reculer
rebondir grandir le mouvement créé une
histoire une histoire qui parfois n'a
aucun sens on peut lui donner un sens
grâce à un script on a le choix de se
mettre en mouvement d'abord trouvé
l'histoire pendant ou le contraire ou
alors le jamais deux les deux ans un
long moment en 2015
j'ai cofondé le studio de motion design
ilevel qu'ils à sydney est ce que vous
voyez derrière moi c'est le demos et la
démo de mon studio dans mon travail mes
clients me demandent de réaliser des
vidéos en motion design et il m'en pose
souvent une histoire que je dois mettre
en forme et en mouvement je suis plus
souvent l'instrumentiste que le chef
d'orchestre
car dans le cadre de commandes il est
rare d'avoir carte blanche mais je me la
suis donné en 2016
j'ai coréalisé le clip où elle tsung que
vous voyez là le clip work song est un
hommage à l'art aborigène au chamanisme
et raconte un voyage initiatique
j'ai écouté la musique de wells en
boucle pendant des jours et j'ai imaginé
des tas d'histoires jusqu'à en choisir
une
la plus proche de celle que je veux
raconter que je veux transmettre que je
veux ressentir
on redonne tous une petite musique de
l'hôte est tous les jours
souvent avec les mêmes paroles le même
refrain qui racontent la même histoire
agréable ou désagréable à écouter nous
nous racontons des histoires à longueur
de journée et elles jouent un rôle
essentiel dans la décision dans le
mouvement et vous aujourd'hui
quelle est votre histoire ou plutôt
quelle est celle que vous voulez vous
raconter
quel sens voulez vous donnez à vos
études à votre travail à vos relations
on peut transformer à l'infini
l'histoire d'un clip pour l'améliorer
pour la rendre plus réel plus fidèle à
ce que l'on imagine comme on peut le
faire dans notre propre vie j'étais un
point habitant à paris qui avait décidé
d'aller vivre en australie
parmi des milliers d'autres brin des
milliers de points que l'on retrouve
dans les offres fascinante des
aborigènes
ils ont deux couleurs vives ou d'une
palette d'offres et représente
précisément l'espace comme autant de
cartes de leur terre et du ciel
leur histoire est vieille de soixante
millions et les aborigènes la raconte
dans des champs des récits des arts et
mon passage en australie a duré quatre
ans période durant laquelle j'ai
découvert une toute petite partie de
leur culture mais je m'en suis imprégné
un maximum dans la réalisation du clip
racing
chaque découverte chaque expérience
chaque rencontre peut être source
d'inspiration
et même si non nous récoltons pas les
fruits aujourd'hui
immédiatement cette incubation créatif
est nécessaire à la réalisation d'un
film et à sa propre réalisation
[Musique]
un jour elle permet de connecter tous
les points entre eux en motion design il
est important de se baser sur des
réseaux sur des références existantes
je le fais aussi personnellement dans ma
vie je ne savais pas si je voulais des
enfants
alors j'ai recherché des références
extérieures des modèles qui m'inspire
des amis qui ont des enfants et qui ne
sacrifie pas leur vie qui continue à
avoir une carrière qui continuent à
voyager et qui continue à s'épanouir et
professionnellement
l'une de mes plus grandes références et
le designer stefan sagmeister parce qu
bien sûr son travail en design est
exceptionnel mais il a aussi énormément
réfléchi au concept du bonheur et c'est
une manière de design et sa vie et vous
qui vous inspirent aujourd'hui quelles
sont vos références la vie d'un écrivain
un ami qui s'épanouit dans son couple
depuis plus de 15 ans imaginez-vous en
face de cette personne qui vous
inspirent tant un professeur un parent
un ami
une personne que vous n'avez jamais
rencontré vous êtes deux points là en
place de l'autre et on a mis le temps
sur pause plus rien ne bouge
observer ces deux fois vous pouvez
imaginer que vous êtes deux points en
train de prendre un café et à ce moment
là vous n'êtes que deux points il n'y a
pas de passé pas de futur pas
d'histoires plus de temps vous n'êtes
que deux points plus rien ne vous
différencie vous êtes d'eux mêmes points
et pourtant dès lors qu'on aura pu
rassure plaît ces deux points iront dans
des directions différentes
la pesanteur d'une atmosphère tirera
l'un de ses points vers le bas alors
qu'il n'ya aucune gravité dans la
situation où certaines résistances le
freineront dans ses mouvements
alors que l'autre point aura pris de la
hauteur et saura rebondir
les références sont importantes car
elles sont des piliers à la réalisation
de films comme à sa propre réalisation
elle nous inspirent nos guides nous
aiguille et stimule notre imagination
combien de fois vous êtes vous fait des
films après un récit d'aventurés après
une rencontre passionnante
le générant tous des images mentales des
univers imaginaires qui deviennent de
plus en plus réelle si on répète le
scénario au quotidien le scénario réduit
la distance entre l'imagination et la
réalité
le scénario du clip all things est basé
sur des récits de rêves chamanique
le héros se fait happer par un serpent
une porte d'entrée à son voyage
initiatique dans une forêt luxuriante
il ne fait plus qu'un avec la nature il
est traversé d'émotion incroyable
laissant place à des lieux sombres et de
cendres les plantes clède a retrouvé son
corps physique et lui donne un pouvoir
de guérison qui lui permet de rentrer de
sa quête walsum raconte cette histoire
découpé en c'est ce plan on appelle ça
un storyboard un story board est un
document qui ressemble à une bd il est
fait de plein de petites cases et
montrent toutes les étapes du film élit
chaque scène entre elles de la première
à la dernière seconde je les applique
aussi dans ma vie j'ai réuni toutes les
images que je veux vivre que je veux
ressentir dans ma vie future
et je les ai imaginé en travaillant tous
les jours et je les ai posé sur une
feuille comme un story board
j'en ai un dans mon bureau un chez moi
nous nous faisons tous des films j'ai
décidé d'en faire mon métier mon support
est à l'écran mais pour chacun d'entre
nous le support et la réalité nous
sommes capables de réaliser des films
qui sortent directement de notre
imagination
nous sommes capables de composer des
musiques que nous jouons dans le tête
nous sommes capables de construire des
bâtiments que nous avons dessiné dans
l'eau au rêve
on peut bâtir des palais comme on peut
bâtir des mondes intérieurs dans nos
vies il ya quelques temps
j'écoutais un podcast dans lequel lucas
giacomoni définit le monde comme la
somme de tous les mondes de chacun
d'entre nous
comme on dirait l'humanité est la somme
de tous les êtres humains
la réalité n'est pas ce qui nous entoure
la réalité est une construction
psychologique social narrative
on change de réalité quand on change de
narration et quand on change de
narration on rentre dans une réalité
nouvelle
nous sommes autant de points qui lie à
deux réalités différentes
la dernière étape et l'animation le
mouvement en motion design plus le
nombre d'image par seconde est élevé
plus le mouvement est fluide
c'est pour ça qu'on utilise en général
24 25 images par seconde en motion
design en 2018
je suis rentré vivre à paris j'étais ce
point qui avait fait un aller-retour
espacé de 4 ans soit plus de 126
millions d'image et quand je suis revenu
à paris de ce rallye j'ai connu un
passage à vide
j'étais devenu un point statique un
point d'ordre pour un temps un temps qui
s'était étendu le nombre d'image s'était
réduit et tout paraissait moins fluide
il manquait des images entre chacune
d'elles
c'est comme si le point que j'étais avec
part perdu des parties de lui-même dans
trop de mouvements le mouvement avait
précédé le script et j'avais décidé
d'inverser le processus cette fois
écrire l'histoire d'abord et me mettre
en mouvement ensuite comme pour le clip
work songs le film a été récompensé et
savoir que me libérer de toutes
contraintes et limites esthétique et
narrative on a été la clé m'a permis de
croire en mon processus créatif
et donc à mon retour en france j'ai
voulu faire l'expérience ce processus
dans ma vie personnelle
le film est devenu réel une réalité est
ce qui donne existence et une
imagination a une histoire
on est tous un point statique maintenant
et on peut décider de lui donner du sens
par l'histoire et par le mouvement
merci
[Applaudissements]